ce sont les propos polémiques de la
semaine et ils sont signés Vincent
Cassel dans une interview donnée au
journal britannique The Guardian
l'acteur français a choqué en déclarant
c'est presque honteux d'être un homme de
nos jours vous devez être plus féminin
plus vulnérable mais écoutez si les
hommes deviennent trop vulnérables et
trop féminins je pense qu'il va y avoir
un problème en pleine promo de sa
nouvelle série en Angleterre les
déclarations de la star du cinéma ont
très rapidement traversé la Manche et
choquer une bonne partie de la France
dès qu'on commence à parler et qu'on dit
quelque chose on dérange forcément
quelqu'un et ce n'est pas faux car en
plus d'avoir été lynché sur les réseaux
pour les internautes certaines
personnalités comme Charles Berling ont
également tenu à exprimer à Vincent
Cassel leur désaccord c'est n'importe
quoi j'aime beaucoup Vincent mais en
quoi le fait d'exprimer sa part de
féminité serait dégradant on peut dire
qu'il appartient à une époque où les
hommes ne faisaient pas grand-carts de
la sensibilité féminine l'ex-mari de
Monica Bellucci affirme néanmoins qu'il
n'est pas misogyne pour autant car toute
sa vie il a été entouré de femmes
importantes à ses yeux incroyable
incroyable et vous êtes -vous choqué par
les propos de Vincent Cassel
alors moi ce qui m'amuse c'est que les
deux qui sont entre guillemets de la
génération de Vincent Cassel Laurent et
mon Jean-Mi sont pas choqués pourquoi tu
es pas choqués Jean-Mi bah non parce que
je sais pas moi je trouve que il y a une
sorte de bon sens aussi parce que les
femmes de en tout cas les femmes je
rencontrais elles exigent en tout cas me
demander une certaine virilité c'est
elle voulait pas que je leur ressemble
comme moi je leur demandais pas qu'elles
aient les mêmes goûts que moi que ça
soit en terme de de sortir de hobbies de
sport de choses qu'on regarde à la
télévision on a chacun notre univers que
chacun elle sache ou pas sa choquant qui
se retrouve pas ou qui est peu de liens
de rencontres c'est pas très grave parce
que on se respecte un autre qu'on est
amoureux et qu'on devine une belle
histoire d'amour je vois pas pourquoi on
devrait épouser forcément deviennent
trop vulnérables et trop féminin je
pense qu'on aura véritablement un
problème moi je suis d'accord attends je
vais prendre un autre nom de la
génération de gens moi je suis pas
choqué parce que je trouve que c'est ni
choquant ni pas choquant j'aurais pu
être choqué éventuellement faire plaisir
aux femmes qui sont là je pense que tout
simplement il donne son avis d'hommes de
son âge cette génération là et il trouve
que il y a peut-être un peu de dérivant
en ce moment et il y a des débats sur le
sujet voilà maintenant je peux
comprendre qu'il est qu'il est son avis
mais aussi
qui lui a répondu dans la presse là
c'est que quelque part faudrait aussi
attention à ce que ce mouvement soit pas
cassé par des propos comme ça parce que
c'est bien aussi que les femmes prennent
leur place donc c'est un peu une réponse
de l'ordre si vous êtes un fan de
Formule 1 vous est-ce que vous avez
envie que dans les Grands Prix et autant
d'hommes que de femmes qui courent sur
les qui concourent en Formule 1
le petit problème qui peut avoir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on veut absolument que
homme et femme soit pareille homme et
femme pareil tu le montres qui se dirige
pas pareil le cerveau n'est pas pareil
ils sont pas construit pareil et on veut
que tout soit pareil c'est vrai que
femme un homme par exemple un pilote de
Formule 1 pour le dire il perd 4 kg par
Grand Prix ils ont essayé de mettre des
femmes elles courent 4 secondes plus
lentement et c'est normal
mais c'est un autre sujet mais c'est
pour dire que arrêtez de vouloir
peut-être tout mettre au même niveau
alors il y a et on peut défendre
alors déjà je comprends pas en quoi on
aura un problème si on a des hommes un
peu plus efféminés de nos jours je vois
pas ce que ça poserait problème et
malheureusement vous réalisez tous
intelligents autour de cette table mais
moi j'ai regardé les commentaires qu'il
y avait sous cette interview et
malheureusement il y a des personnes que
je trouve clairement homophobes qui sont
les commentaires sont intelligents pour
dire il a raison on en a marre des
[__] on en a marre sur les réseaux
toi
on demandait maintenant à
systématiquement aux acteurs est-ce que
vous faites la vaisselle est-ce que vous
partagez les personnages et là où je
rejoins va s'encasel il dit c'est
presque une honte d'être un homme de nos
jours et tu vois les acteurs qui étaient
là qui disent pas que je perdentes
respirateur pardon pardon Mathieu moi je
trouve que c'est une honte qu'un homme
fasse pas la vaisselle et fasse pas le
tâche ménager bien sûr excuse-moi pardon
il se livrer je dis oui vous vous croyez
vous croyez pas je fais la vaisselle à
la maison je passe l'aspi ça me dérange
absolument pas moi il y a pas
que ce travail là doit être dédié alors
j'ai attends choqué Benoît donc je vais
finir là et choqué après évidemment
Déborah non mais moi je pense que du
coup l'homme et la femme est très
complémentaire et moi je suis pour
l'homme alpha si tu veux c'est depuis la
nuit des temps c'est animal c'est dans
le cerveau c'est comme ça déjà l'homme
est plus puissant physiquement il y a
plein de choses il protège il rassure la
femme elle est plus en retrait c'est
comme ça maintenant on est dans une
modernité ou maintenant les femmes
veulent avoir une paire de couilles mais
ça marche pas comme ça
je suis désolé
ça va poser problème s'il y a trop de
gens comme toi plus tard bah si ça va
poser des problèmes
tout à l'heure notre génération on n'a
pas vu nos pères pleurer on n'a pas vu
nos paires nous prendre dans les bras on
n'a pas vu nos pères avoir des gestes
dit féminins parce qu'on est frustré un
truc à la con chez eux moi pardon je
j'estime que je finis masculin ni
féminin quand je prends mes gosses dans
les bras quand je fais une vaisselle
enfin je me sens donc une femme c'est
pareil mais non je pose des questions
beaucoup de sujet oui pourquoi
et moi c'est pour ça que ça me choque
parce qu'en fait il associe la
vulnérabilité aux femmes mais les hommes
sont extrêmement vulnérables aussi moi
je pense que les femmes sont très fortes
elles accouchent les enfants elles ont
un côté très fort aussi les femmes donc
le fait d'associer ce côté vulnérable
parce qu'il dit vulnérable féminin mais
en fait les hommes sont très vulnérables
et lui qui est un acteur d'ailleurs et
très vulnérable aussi
quand on demande aux femmes ce qu'elle
recherche d'abord chez un homme alors
les mecs c'est toujours hyper grossier
les mecs qu'elle soit bonne et Machin
les femmes elles répondent gentille et
protecteurs mais ça c'est parce que
effectivement c'est depuis la nuit des
temps comme disait Laurent voilà l'homme
est plus fort physiquement que la femme
et c'est très bien et ça va très bien
comme ça je pense que le discours est
plus global peut-être que voilà il est
l'ancienne génération mais moi aussi
j'ai pas tellement envie qu'on gomme le
genre de toute façon on n'arrivera
jamais à gommer le genre voilà on est
tous on est chacun chacun on est genré
et c'est comme ça et tant mieux et le
monde s'en va j'imagine un feu rouge
quelqu'un te fait un machin et tout ça
et mec est là vas-y toi chérie va lui
péter la gueule
je sais pas alors Isa ça m'énerve quand
on fait semblant de pas comprendre ce
que quelqu'un veut dire alors
pardonne-moi des mots mais c'est vrai
qu'on dit il faut pas dire ça parce que
moi mais si on fait ça en fonction du
fait que ça va être mal interprété on
dit encore moins que rien c'est mal
interprète là
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire quelque chose
d'ailleurs il dit bien je sais que je
vais me faire lâcher et il avait raison
parce qu'il est en terrain minet et il
le sait il veut simplement dire qu'à
l'heure actuelle l'homme il a tout faux
aux yeux des néo féministes il a tout
faux ils sont plus le droit de dire ça
ils ont plus le droit de faire ça ils
ont le droit de rien faire il faut qu'il
laisse leur bonne femme faire le
barbecue ils veulent ils vont plus et
c'est ce qui veut dire est-ce qu'on est
à quelque chose à y gagner si l'homme
profondément au nom au titre millénaire
millénaire du duel il n'est plus un
homme on est personne n'a rien à y
gagner c'est vrai moi
pour comprendre ce qui veut dire qui me
gonfle ici dans le sens d'Isabelle mais
avec un bémol en fait il cultive la
virilité et il l'assume complètement si
vous allez sur son compte Instagram vous
verrez il prend des pauses à la Delon il
fait des sports extrêmes il montre ses
muscles etc
effectivement il a il a un côté de long
qui l'a su mais et voilà en revanche il
rebondit quand on lui pose la question
et rebondit sur un personnage qui
s'appelle Andrew Tate qui est assez
sulfureux absolument un personnage
extrêmement misogyne et qui l'expose de
façon très vulgaire et grossir sur les
réseaux et le problème c'est que Vincent
Cassel il le cite en disant qu'il ne dit
pas que des bêtises et là je pense qu'il
fait une grave erreur comme il l'avait
déjà fait en 2017 quand il avait joué
Gauguin et que Léa Salamé lui avait dit
que bon il jouait quand même un
personnage qui a des relations avec une
fille de 13 ans et il avait dit oui mais
à l'époque les filles de 13 ans c'était
pas vraiment les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui
mais pardon il fait pas d'erreur il est
intelligent encore une fois n'oublie
jamais cette phrase de Badinter ne juge
pas le passé avec les règles du présent
je suis pas d'accord avec vous
je suis désolé mais il peut enfin il
s'exprime il a peut-être mal dit et
cetera mais en fait quand il est à ce
niveau là et quand même
comment tu le dis tu te DOIS parce qu'il
a une position aujourd'hui qui est
puissante il est fort il sait enfin bref
voilà maintenant je suis désolé tu dis
on fait genre on comprend pas bah moi
j'ai peut-être pas niveau culturel de
certains peut-être ben je suis désolé
j'ai pas compris sa phrase et c'était
ambigu c'était à la fois misogyne avec
c'était aussi moi à un moment donné je
me suis dit c'est un peu homophobe quand
même comme phrase j'ai eu cette pensée
là
j'ai le droit de vous dire ce que je
ressens quand je quand je lis cette
phrase
elle était ambiguë elle est mal dit et
je trouve ça humiliant pour les femmes
avec
tout le con tout ce qu'on a tous que les
femmes ont vécu tout ce qu'elles ont
fait pour en arriver à cette entre
guillemets c'est indépendance et ce
niveau d'égalité sur lequel on n'est pas
encore le problème privé à revenir à ça
et à ramener sa phrase aussi
on avait une tondeuse qui s'appelle une
tondeuse Bernard voilà et mon grand-père
tout les samedis allez mettre le pied
dessus il fallait tirer tirer ils
étaient trop petit
il m'a dit le jour où tu démarreras
cette tondeuse Bernard
et un samedi les gars j'ai mis les gaz
[Applaudissements]
bah voilà et je voulais dire tu es fort
tu es machin tu es je trouve que vous
mélangez tout mais non
c'est pas vrai c'est les
plus gentiment
entre 22 et 29 ans ah ouais
on a une pépinière